hi everyone I'm Ilana and welcome to my
Channel today I'm just about to place
might at these might world championships
in Atlanta in Georgia and it's highly
playable on the Xbox one which is really
really exciting so let's go have a look
for those who aren't familiar smart is a
mythology theme third person MOBA
developed by hi-rez Studios who are also
known for making tribes it officially
released in March 2014 and has really
really quickly risen to being one of the
top three most popular mobiles up there
with League of Legends and dota 2 the
prize pool here are the smart World
Championships is 2.5 million with the
third largest eSports prize ever below
dota and dota 2 up all the other major
MOBAs though it's the first one to make
it to consoles I'd argue the only one
that really can thanks to the third
person view it's also the first next gen
mobile full stop though its Xbox one
only but could it come to ps4 eventually
we'll have to wait and see so to quickly
get the Moga basics out of the way
before I talk about how it plays on the
Xbox one specifically just because I had
a few people on social media asked over
the past few days which is kind of
surprising considering it's the most
popular genre in the world but still you
basically play with two teams usually a
five players who will pick their own God
characters that have their own skills
and abilities and a tasked with killing
enemy cards destroying enemy towers
which are situated on each lane of the
map and phoenixes which have to be taken
down to usually after the towers have
been dealt with so in smite to win the
actual game your team has to destroy the
other teams Phoenix's in order to get
access to an enemy Titan which is just
like a giant enemy and then kill bat two
games can take a really long time and
while it can be really hard to make a
comeback when one team has way more gold
and XP than you do because gold buyers
handy items and XP makes you stronger
the fact that there are so many facets
is what keeps really competitive there's
so much more to MOBAs then kill enemy
player this is all the same on the Xbox
one version of course
so smite specifically is different as
said and that you control your God in
third person perspective what other
movers are usually top down topped out
on a console would probably fail pretty
miserably because trying to coordinate
attacks and aim correctly is much much
slower on a console in that kind of view
in third person the difference is only
really noticeable with skill shots and
the auto-aim seems to have been tweaked
a little but it never feels like a
hindrance at all aiming and attacking
with your God's basic spells on the Xbox
one is extremely easy if there are major
differences between the xbox and pc
versions I didn't even notice a lot of
smart players actually already used
controllers on PC so it seems like the
biggest issue they had porting the game
to console was actually tweaking the
user interface I did get to chat about
this with the producer of the xbox one
version Andy Anderson so how much is a
change from the pc version this is the
same game same guys same abilities but
since it is on a on a console now and
you haven't used controller and because
your experience is very different when I
TV versus being on PC we've had to
completely rebuild the game from a UI
interaction standard so we had to
rebuild all the UI's from the landing
page to the main screen to
the height itself is different items so
all those things had to be completely
rebuilt with the consideration of I have
to go to read it after will see it
clearly and understand what it is
digested mentally and make decisions but
also very quickly respond to that with a
very intuitive controls on the control
now keep in mind of what I played was
actually alpha the beta doesn't even
start until later in january and i'm
struggling to find any flaws to point
out at all there were a few connection
issues the button combinations could
potentially be overwhelming and that
there's so much to fit onto a controller
so you occasionally need to press two
bucks it wants to do certain things and
I can imagine it taking a bit of a
learning curve to get used to those kind
of things and there were a few minor
graphical issues but overall it was
pretty much flawless seamless if you
will even know that word has become a
horrible cliche in games reporting in
general though it feels absolutely the
same as the pc version which is
obviously hugely popular and successful
so i'm really looking forward to how
this affects the console market maybe
we'll see loads of console exclusive
MOBAs follow suit or maybe it'll just
crash and burn on an untested market
either way I am excited to watch it all
unfold I'm Ilana and thanks for watching
you